outside of teaching where where have you
made most whether members to do money
because I know you do investments but
most of my wealth today is investment
returns
do you investing that's a really that's
a really interesting topic at the moment
especially with what's happening with
the you know looking like we're
potentially going into a depression and
with the epidemic and everything's
changing what what are you invested in
and is that changing right now
well I'm am i defining an investment as
some product service or idea that serves
ever greater numbers of people that is
not a zero-sum game but a nonzero-sum
game sustainable fair exchange that as
population grows it grows so for
instance toilet paper is something
everybody's going to use for them for as
long as we're around toothpaste it's
going to be something we're going to use
deodorant so anything that is a service
or a product that people will use and
the population for grow and their brand
names and their things that are staples
I buy companies that own those companies
that serve ever greater numbers of
people I'm not much into speculation I
buy quite diverse across the sectors
with indices I keep my cost down my
turnover down my costs down to very low
I reinvest dividends and I just keep my
cost down in my returns hi and I'm
patient and I've been doing that for 38
when I'm 38 years basically and I've
been very blessed by returns the
coronavirus I've made more money during
the coronavirus than ever in history so
I I knew that the market was above the
mean I was waiting for it to go below
the mean I put in a lot of cash reserves
in below the mean and it's come back up
and so I can't complain but I make sure
that no matter what goes on in the
market I
I've structured my portfolio and
structured my investment strategies to
be where if he goes up I win if it goes
down I win
it doesn't matter where it goes you can
win and I'm not trying to make a fortune
overnight but I've made a fortune over
time and I'm a firm believer in
investing in quality companies that
serve vast numbers of people
consistently and not not something
that's a quickest get rich system
there's many of those I pass by I'm just
a patient methodical tortoise compared
to the hare yeah I just keep I keep
buying quality companies that keep
serving people that are staples for
people and if you help other people get
what they want to get life it helps you
get what you want to get life and that's
where the real investment is a
speculation is speculating with a
crystal ball about what you think is
going to happen and sometimes you win
and sometimes you don't and you're
speculating on data that's not really
solid but when you have a long track
record at least 25 years as Charles
Ellis says of a what a mean would be and
you're satisfied with the mean and then
you're expect less than mean so your
your eat fulfill whatever you get you
patiently build up compound interest
which is one of the greatest things you
can ever get in your favor and after a
while that starts multiplying and
exceeding your active income so I'm at
the stage where I'm blessed and not have
to work I work the purpose of financial
independence is to be able to make
enough income where you're not having to
work you work because you love to work
so you're doing something you love and
getting paid for it and then building
momentum of economics on top of that so
that's and I didn't start out that way I
started out saving a you know a dollar
an hour $10 a day
$50 a week $200 a month and then I just
kept increasing that every three months
and I increased it 10% every three
months and I never stopped until it was
a quarter of a million dollars a month
and it was going in to savings and
investments and I just kept buying
companies and I bought real estate over
the time but I'm really more into
companies I understand companies that
better than me dealing with real estate
and real estate has too many variables
that ties it too much capital
too much cash in too many cost that are
unpredictable etc so I prefer to buy
companies myself I have had properties
many many properties over the years but
I closed us down just so like Elon Musk
did this he realized the sinkholes of
lifestyle I'm a property in the UK and I
make good money in property in the UK
but then other people that don't know
anything about property but know a lot
of companies don't know a lot about
maybe from gold or even crypto koozies
all these land cryptocurrencies at all
for me to invest in crypto currencies
would just be a complete gamble we've
stopped in the dark property I know it's
very safe because I risk assess it I do
my due diligence probably in the London
School of Economics there's a credit
susi summary rating that comes out of
there every year it's the greatest
source of information on investment
probably in the world there's a 120 year
track record of documenting every market
in the world summarizing it and I've
watched that for many years and I'm
certain from looking at the stats why I
put my money where I do I've been doing
quite a bit of Studies on it now like
you say there's some people that really
love the real estate market and I know
some very wealthy people in the real
estate market they bought in quality
properties they've invested it they
don't land they developed it they've put
rental and commercial properties
together and they stacked it on top of
each other and they've rebuilt cities
and done extraordinary things some of
the biggest wealth has come from that
but it also takes a bit of a focus and I
have to factor in the time thought focus
and the cost of that my abilities of
that and all that compared to what I do
so that's why I do it it's not that mine
right I just that's what works for me
based on what my needs are as a speaker
but I certainly know people and I spoken
on many property investment programs
where they've made fortunes and I
encourage people to do it but I travel
full-time I don't live anywhere and so I
like to make sure that I have access to
the liquidity that I do but but now I've
seen it where I live I live on a ship as
you know the [ __ ] was yeah so that's a
very interesting place to live
yeah I I am NOT there right now because
it's not available right now
yeah if they kind of docked it
temporarily until the state passes but
there's some very wealthy people there
and there are some very smart people
there and many of them are their
property developers built a fortune
through poverty but like I said I have
my preferences because I understand
businesses more so than the property so
I stick to it I know it's wise to stick
to what you know the cryptocurrencies I
I didn't feel when I investigated that
they had a the way they were set up on
the blockchain of the Mach mining I
didn't think that was a wise investment
not a bed for brokers to to buy itself
but as far as holding that and doing
that I didn't think that had a long-term
future as well as buying quality
companies that serve people so I'd
rather be involved in serving people